during a vaginal childbirth the first
stage of labor lasts about 12 to 19
hours and starts when your baby settles
lower into your pelvis in response your
cervix begins to a face or become
thinner and dilate or widen during this
time you may feel strong regular
contractions occurring every five to 20
minutes and lower back pain and cramping
that doesn't go away you may see a
brownish or reddish mucous discharge
which could be the mucous plug at the
opening of your cervix falling out your
water may break which can either be a
large gush of fluid or a continuous
trickle if you experience any of these
symptoms contact your doctor or Midwife
to see if you should go to the hospital
at the beginning of stage 2 of labor
which usually lasts from 20 minutes to 2
hours your cervix is fully dilated to 10
centimeters and your baby's head has
moved beyond the cervical opening into
your birth canal your doctor or Midwife
will instruct you to push during your
contractions and rest between them in a
normal delivery your baby's head will
rotate to face your back during active
labor your uterus is divided into an
active segment that contracts pushing
the baby downward and a flexible passive
segment that remains relaxed stretching
to provide more room for the baby to
pass through when the top of your baby's
head appears or crowns
your doctor may make a small cut called
an episiotomy to enlarge the vaginal
opening
then your doctor or Midwife will give
you instructions on how to push your
baby out as your baby's head passes
through the birth canal it molds into an
elongated shape an elongated head shape
will resolve itself within a few days as
the skull bones shift back into place
after your baby's head exits the birth
canal his or her head and shoulders will
rotate to help the shoulders pass
through the birth canal your baby's
shoulders are delivered one after the
other in order to fit through your
pelvis
once the shoulders emerge the rest of
your baby slides out easily
after your baby is born his or her
umbilical cord will be cut in stage 3 of
labor which may last five to 30 minutes
mild contractions will help push the
placenta out of the uterus during this
stage you and your baby may begin
bonding through skin-to-skin contact and
breastfeeding
[Music]